more than 50 people are dead and well
over 500 injured after a gunman opened
fire at a Las Vegas Music Festival late
Sunday night it's the deadliest mass
shooting in US history and now Sin
City's biggest headliners are weighing
in on social media Britney Spears who
has a residency in Vegas tweeted that
she is quote completely heartbroken a
sentiment Jennifer Lopez echoed on
Instagram writing feeling so broken this
morning Celine Dion tweeted that she was
praying for all the innocent victims and
their families Jenna Dewan Tatum whose
husband Channing Tatum produces Magic
Mike live in Vegas admitted she had
quote no words the Backstreet Boys wrote
that they are quote in shock while
Mariah Carey said she's horrified and
Elton John said he's quote utterly
devastated by the tragedy cher expressed
her condolences for the victims on
Twitter and Calvin Harris shared his
upset et has learned that many Vegas
shows will be canceled tonight in the
wake of the shooting boys to men who is
scheduled to perform this weekend
tweeted quote can't wait to hug you all
[Music]